the pacific island nation of tonga has
virtually lost contact with the rest of
the world after saturday's volcanic
eruption cut the country's internet
cable the full extent of the damage to
the country remains unclear new zealand
and australia have sent military planes
to survey this situation from above
other flights to deliver aid are also
planned the underwater eruption on
saturday sent shock waves across the
pacific tsunami warnings were issued for
many countries as far away as peru and
there two people have drowned after
unusually high waves hit the west coast
of the americas
this is the aftermath of the tsunami
that hit the shorelines of peru over ten
thousand kilometers away from the
explosion in tonga
the underwater eruption was so powerful
that it was detected around the world
these satellite images show gas and ash
being thrown thousands of meters into
the earth's atmosphere
communication links to tonga have been
damaged but the capital has sustained
significant damage says new zealand's
prime minister jacinda arden this is
where there's of course a you know an
urgency here we want to make sure that
we're there on the ground as soon as
possible but for our navy vessels it
will take several days to reach tonga
we need to finally balance the need to
get there quickly but to make sure we
also get the people and resources they
need there as well and in some cases we
have parts of tonga we've just not even
been able to establish communication
people in new zealand said they received
no warning of the tsunami even though
the volcano's explosion could be heard
in some parts of the country
many were still out on the water on
their boats which have suffered severe
damage
japan was also put on high alert
thousands evacuated their homes coming
to shelters like this in order to stay
safe
i heard the tsunami would be as high as
a meter but we really don't know how
high it could reach
i thought it would be best to evacuate
so i came here
these fishermen assess the damage
scenes echoed on coastlines across the
pacific region
let's bring in roger maynard he's a
freelance correspondent uh in sydney
roger australia and new zealand have
both sent a surveillance planes to
assess the damage from this uh eruption
what are they equipped with and what
will they be looking for
well the new zealand defence force has
sent an orion aircraft from auckland to
carry out an aerial assessment and any
damage to low-lying islands and here in
australia the minister of foreign
affairs has announced that the royal
australian air force is planning to
undertake surveillance activity over the
affected area too the problem they face
is the ash cloud which has the potential
to interfere with aircraft engines and
of course severely reduced visibility
but both countries have had to deal with
these sorts of crises in the past so
they do have the experience and the
knowledge to monitor the aftermath to
volcanic eruptions like this one
our communications with tonga have been
interrupted as we've heard what are you
hearing about the situation on the
island
well the exact toll from this major
eruption is still far from clear
information about the impact on tonga
and surrounding islands has lacked
significant detail because of the
underwater communications cable which
links it with the outside world
apparently being severed or at least
barely damaged in the eruption
as a result phone lines and internet
activity have been interrupted but what
we do know has come from sources here in
australia who have had limited satellite
communication with the islands the
tongan deputy head of mission here in
australia says there have been no
confirmed deaths so far and only minimal
damage to the coastal site of the
capital nakaloafa however there are
several surrounding islands and coastal
areas which have been out of contact and
there's been no word from these more
isolated parts the new zealand prime
minister jacinda roder has reported that
a thick film of volcanic dust has
enveloped much of the area contaminating
water supplies such has been the level
of thick ash that many tongans have been
forced to wear face masks and drink
bottled water a video that's somehow
been posted on social media described
one family who'd been sheltering from a
rain of volcanic ash and tiny pieces of
rock that had turned the sky black it's
really bad said an eyewitness with
locals being told to stay indoors and
cover windows and entrances because of
the danger
so australia and new zealand are already
major eight donors too tonga will they
be stepping up support now
well both countries will most certainly
be offering food manpower and technical
support wherever it's needed hmas
adelaide which is a helicopter docking
ship and the largest vessel of its kind
ever built for the australian navy will
reportedly be making its way to the area
soon the ship is currently here in
sydney and will sail to brisbane to be
loaded with supplies for tonga but it
could take several days to get there and
so this will not be a quick and easy
mission to complete
how much extra support will be provided
by australia and new zealand will depend
on the scale of the emergency which as i
say is still largely unknown but given
the power of the eruption and the plume
of ash climbing hundreds if not
thousands of meters into the air
according to some reports the long-term
impact is likely to be considerable
roger maynard there in sydney for us
thank you roger
thank you
well let's bring in shane cronin he's a
volcanologist from the university of
auckland shane what can you tell us
about this eruption just how powerful
was it
yeah um so there was a it was an
extremely powerful event and so
uh it was very short-lived so when you
compare it to other eruptions it's quite
difficult but essentially uh during the
short
less than ten minute long eruption the
power it released was very similar to
that of the 1991 eruption of pinatubo in
the philippines and so it sent shock
waves around the world
uh literally so pressure waves actually
atmospheric pressure waves they traveled
around the world and in some parts of
the world on the other uh on the other
side of the globe from uh from tonga
they actually got two lots of shock
waves one traveling one side of the
globe and the other traveling around the
other side of the globe so it's
remarkable from that perspective so also
remarkable with these tsunamis
generated
so what kind of damage from your
experience what kind of damage uh can we
expect there because we don't hear
anything from tonga because
communication links are down
yeah we have actually heard some
some recent information now uh and the
ashford ontonga has been uh has been
present but not as severe as we were
fearing um so and also the damage to
from the tsunami uh has been actually
less severe than we were expecting so
far no reports of fatalities
so um it seems uh even though the
eruption was extremely powerful that
enormous damage has not yet
been reported in tonga and it
it's now just really waiting to see from
the far-flung small low-lying islands
whether anyone else has been affected
so this volcano began erupting
intermittently in december but this
major eruption seems to have come with
no advanced warning why is that
yeah well partly the reason is this
volcano is located 65 kilometers from
any major population center
so and it's a very isolated no one lives
on the on the volcanic island it's
extremely harsh environment there is no
coral reef around it it's uh battered by
the seas and the elements i've i've been
there i've came down on that island and
you know it's extremely difficult to
keep
equipment running so the only way to
monitor a volcano like that is to use
satellite methods um and
they are often mostly reactionary rather
than providing us a pre-warning
shane cronin there have volcanologists
in auckland thank you very much
thanks for talking
you